together Hindu and Muslim Community
leaders have called for an end to weeks
of violent disturbances in Leicester
so what's caused the clashes and how did
they begin
[Music]
police say they're investigating several
incidents of violence in the city on
Saturday the 17th of September bottles
were thrown during violent scenes
between a group of Hindus and a group of
Muslims in the east of the city it began
with a Hindu March that led to a clash
with Muslims bottles were thrown as
police tried to separate the two sides
and on Sunday the 18th of September
police formed according to prevent
Muslim protesters getting any closer to
the Hindu temple on belgrave road after
a video circulating on social media
showed a flag had been removed from the
temple the previous night angering
Hindus
[Music]
weeks earlier violence had broken out
after a cricket match between India and
Pakistan on the 28th of August India won
the match and during the celebrations
that followed the word disputed claims
that some Indians took part in chance
that roughly translate to death to
Pakistan although we've spoken to some
activists who say cricket isn't the
reason behind the clashes
provoking us provoking us
the answer to what's caused the violence
differs depending on who you ask there
are individuals on both sides of the
argument blaming one another for the
violence and this narrative has been
picked up on by Outlets abroad in India
the alt-right news portal of India has
published articles blaming Muslims for
attacks on Hindus in Pakistan media have
also reported on it in a one-sided way
Muslim activists claim their Community
is being targeted by right-wing Hindu
nationalists
so what is Hindu nationalism it's the
idea that the Hindu Faith should shape
the state and its policies
since the BJP came to power in 2014 led
by Narendra Modi Hindu nationalism has
come to dominate the Indian political
landscape hindutva is now widely
practiced under the present government
and is associated with intolerance of
minorities and anti-muslim sentiments
there's an ideology that has been played
out in the streets of Leicester that
maybe looked at a national scale
International level so we have seen in
India at this moment in time but the
treatment of minorities including
Christians including dalits and
including Muslims which is now being
transferred to the streets of Leicester
so we have evidence of Muslim
individuals being attacked for no other
reason but their faith and when this
starts being paid out along with all the
other micro incidences that's all
culminating into this and then we had a
flash point when a cricket match
happened which had nothing really to do
with these matter but it was seen as a
Flashpoint to ignite everything that
Hindus who joined the march on Saturday
the 17th of September dispute the claim
that there are links to far-right groups
one man who wishes to remain anonymous
told us the protest was supposed to be
peaceful and was organized because of
attacks on his community by Muslims we
just wanted to make a stand that this is
not fair on us that you guys have been
coming to our streets breaking and
smashing things so we just organized a
march to show the support for our
community we can't have this any longer
is this rooted in right wing Hindu
ideology no it's just about taking a
stand
the mayor and police agree that
misinformation on WhatsApp groups and
social media is fueling the violence
on Tuesday the 20th of September
disorder spread to Smith in the West
Midlands Leicester East MP has said
police and Community leaders need to act
urgently to put a stop to the violence
we the family of Leicester
stand in front of you not only as Hindus
and Muslims but as brothers and sisters
we together
call upon the Insiders of hatred to
leave our city alone
Lester has no place for foreign
extremist ideology that causes division
causes behind what happened here in
Leicester are complex the need to
resolve it crucial